اصوات القصف تهدر مجددا في خير صوت
قصف لا يتوقف على طول ضفتين نهر النيبر
النهر الذي كان يوما مصدر جذب سياحي
للمدينه الجنوبيه بات نقطه مشتعله بين
الاوكرانيين والروس فالقوات الروسيه التي
سيطرت على غير سون في بدايه الحرب تقهرت
الى الضفه الشرقيه من النار هذه اخر نقطه
استطعنا الوصول اليها عند احدى ضفاف نهر
دنبر في خيرسون من الجهه الاوكرانيه
القوات الروسيه تتواجد في تلك المنطقه من
الضفه الاخرى القصف يتواصل بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه في هذه الاثناء
يقول الجيش الاوكراني انه يسعى الى اخراج
الروس من اخر معاقلهم على ضفه النار
العدو على الضفه المقابله انه يقصف
عشوائيا الوضع يزداد خطوره لكننا مصرون
على اخضاعه في خرسون
على الضفه الاوكرانيه محاصرون بين مصير
الغامض ودوي انفجارات متبادله لا تهدا
البناء
بات مهجوره لكنه اخر حراسه اثر البقاء
وحيدا مع كلبه رغم خطوره الوضع
يعمل يوري على حمايه بعض مستودعات الميناء
مقابل ثلاثه دولارات في اليوم غير ان
شظايا الحرب طالت كثيرا مما يحرسه
لا اعرف اين يمكنني الاختباء لكنني احاول
البقاء على قيد الحياه
من استمرار
ههه
مؤمنون بان كل شيء سيعود كما كان لن اغادر
الى اي مكان ولدت هنا وسابقى هنا نؤمن
بجيش هنا بقيه انجلينا برفقه جارتها الونه
لكنها رفضت المغامره بحياه ابنتها
واحفادها فارسلتهم الى بولندا
احاول حمايه نفسي
يامل
نهر دنبر يعتقدون ان كل خطوه اوكرانيه الى
الامام